se espera una parálisis legislativo una
parálisis política acá en Washington
porque la cámara de representantes es
normalmente la que propone proyectos de
ley que después pasan al senado y
después a la presidencia para su firma
sin embargo ahora que la cámara de
representantes está en mayoría de los
republicanos y el senado de la mayoría
demócrata pues entonces va a haber una
parálisis ahí y va a ser muy poca las
leyes y los proyectos de ley que se van
a poder aprobar Joe desde el ejecutivo
tendrá la opción de seguir avanzando su
agenda política en cambio climático
contra la inflación y a favor de proveer
servicios de salud y educación un poco
más accesibles al pueblo estadounidense
a través de órdenes ejecutivas pero pues
es de Resaltar esa parálisis que muchos
esperan en los próximos dos años va a
ocurrir acá en Washington además de
Resaltar también que en este momento se
llevó a cabo la votación para confirmar
el presidente de la cámara de
representantes pero
dijo que no va a tener los votos
suficientes para lograr estas este este
los 218 escaños necesarios para
confirmarse y la votación se alargará
entonces en la tarde o en la noche para
lograr esta mayoría Y definir Entonces
el próximo presidente de la cámara de
representantes republica